suite tenté d'en apprendre un peu plus
on va retrouver en direct notre invité
et agnès callamard bonjour
vous êtes secrétaire général d'amnesty
international nous était anciennement
rapporteur spécial sur les exécutions
extrajudiciaires sommaires et
arbitraires première question avec avec
vous peut-être sur sur les combats en
eux mêmes les côté ukrainien on affirme
que des civils ont été ont été ciblés
est ce que c'est quelque chose dont vous
avez eu vent est ce que d'une certaine
manière cela fait partie d'une une
volonté russe de cibler peut-être d'aidé
civile ukrainien en tout cas ça fait
certainement partie de leurs habitudes
que ce soit en syrie ou en tchétchénie
ou en effet dans les provinces
indépendante de l'ukraine les provinces
de dambach mais ce que nous nous avons
pu remarquer depuis le début des
hostilités
c'est que les attaques russes sont
plutôt de type aveugle et je crois que
votre reporter l'a bien confirmé juste
maintenant en parlant de deux
bombardements aveugles sur sur les
habitations civiles donc ceci va à
l'encontre du droit international ceci
va à l'encontre dé loin qui devrait
régir qui devrait régir la guerre les
bombardements contre des civils ou
contre des objets civile de façon non
discriminés et absolument prohibée et à
l'heure actuelle ce que nous remarquons
tu sais qu'il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup trop ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est les armes qui
sont utilisés pour ces bombardements
nous avons nous remarquer amnesty
international l'utilisation de missiles
balistiques nous avons remarqué
et documenté l'utilisation d'armes à
fragmentation ça aussi ce sont en tout
cas la deuxième les armes à
fragmentation sont prohibées
au niveau du droit international ce sont
des gens qui ont
une portée très large qui ne permet pas
à ce qu'ils étirent de viser
correctement sur des cibles militaires
donc les pots que la sophie civils sont
automatiquement
victimes dans le cadre de ce conflit
depuis trois-quatre jours des écoles ont
été ciblés nous avons documenté quatre
écoles qui ont été ciblés plusieurs
civils des enfants des hôpitaux qui ont
été ciblés donc tout ça c'est là la
preuve que malgré les propos du ministre
de la défense russe qui dit ne pas
cibler les civils sais c'est que tu as
fait tout à fait faux les civils sont
les premières victimes crient madame
calama voulais je voulais vous venez de
l'évoquer à l'instant gelé vous posez la
question justement sur les hôpitaux qui
aurait été attaqué certains témoignages
le rapportait effectivement depuis
terrain c'est quelque chose que vous
vous nous avez dit vous avez pu
confirmer
[Musique]
sur l'utilisation de missiles
balistiques vous vous lavez également
également confirmé certains ont été en
s'était d'ailleurs annoncé ont été tirés
depuis la biélorussie vert vers
l'ukraine là encore c'est cette une
utilisation prohiber les missiles
balistiques ou ça fait malheureusement
partie de la guerre j'ai envie de dire
à fragmentation les missiles les
missiles balistiques ce sont des armes
explosifs qui ont des des effets très
vaste dans des zones qui sont densément
peuplées donc
sur les missiles balistiques ne
permettent pas de discriminer entre des
cibles militaires et des cibles civiles
donc a priori elle ne devrait pas être
utilisé dans dans le dans tout cas pas
dans des zones urbaines en ce qui
concerne les armes à fragmentation elles
sont prohibés absolument prohibée un mot
également également avec vous et agnès
callamard sur l'accueil des réfugiés on
a vu des centaines pour l'instant un peu
plus de 200 milles ukrainiens qui ont
fui leur pays en direction des pays
voisins de l'union européenne notamment
comment doit réagir selon vous l'union
européenne comme on doit elle à
accueillir ces réfugiés ukrainien selon
vous
[Musique]
tout ce qui concerne le droit
international pour la protection des
réfugiés s'impose à l'heure actuelle
s'imposer déjà ailleurs d'ailleurs pour
pour d'autres réfugiés donc il faut
absolument que l'union européenne mette
en oeuvre ses obligations en matière de
droit de réfugiés quelque chose qu'elle
n'a pas fait dans le passé par rapport à
des populations de réfugiés qui venaient
d'autres régions mais là il ya au moins
350 mille réfugiés qui seraient arrivés
en pologne et il y en a beaucoup plus
probablement plus plus le les conflits
perdurent et s'étendent et plus les gens
vont s'enfuir enfin ce qu'ils ont dans
la possibilité donc il est absolument
essentiel que les états européens m en
met en place une
solidarité européenne rapport à ces
réfugiés premièrement il est aussi
indispensable de mettre en place des
corridors humanitaires afin que
premièrement les réfugiés puissent
partir ceux qui le veulent et que
deuxièmement les organisations
humanitaires qui veulent apporter
du soutien aux populations qui demeurent
encore en ukraine puisse le faire à
l'heure actuelle d'après l'om est ce
donc l'organisation mondiale de la santé
les hôpitaux commencent à manquer
terriblement
d'oxygène entre autres choses et donc il
est indispensable qu'on puisse alimenter
de façon très rapide
les hôpitaux de et et tout ce qui va
concerner la cuy humanitaire aux
populations qui demeure encore la grande
majorité d'ailleurs demeure en ukraine
merci beaucoup agnès callamard d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur france 24 je
rappelle que vous êtes sécrétaire
général d'amnesty international encore